what I hate most about Matt Walsh
proficiency aside has to be he
looks like he'd sit near him at a
brewery and think oh oh God I bet
this is drinking IPA and then he
is and then you think oh oh God I
bet he's going to tell me about it and
then he does
he's right about you're right about the
first part definitely drinking the ipas
not the second uh I'm not the guy that's
going to strike up a conversation with
you at the bar the first part you're
correct but also I don't understand the
whole thing oh I bet you drink ipas like
it's an insult it is yeah I like beer
that tastes good you you caught me I
don't think of Miss what you're thinking
miss you you got me is that supposed I
don't why is that an insult IPA
objectively just the best quality beer
you could find it's beer that actually
tastes like beer oh I bet you're the
kind of guy who enjoys when you drink a
beverage for it to taste like it's
supposed to taste